you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leak chest
out of work and going to play another
five minute game 500 so how about we go
with E 5 this is rare for me to play e5
and reply to e4 let's see how I fare
okay well I could go with Knight to f6
let's do it we're gonna enter something
wild if they play Knight g5 and I not
quite sure what I would be doing okay
scratch that I was going to take that as
a big learning experience should a 95
play should Knight g5 be played okay so
they're going with a pretty tame
development Bishop outside pawn chain
and then d3 okay well I have a decision
here
I could play Bishop c5 Bishop e7 d5 d6
although I'd be going with this prior to
d6 so what choose one choose one how
about we go with this just a modest
deployment for the bishop but I won't
have any fear at least of a Bishop g5
move and I think I too will play my deep
on a single step so I'm not going to be
so quick to play this move I quite like
seeing Bishop g5 why why are you such a
fan of that I'd really like to see a
dark square Bishop exchange for one
um h6 Bishop h4 Knight h5 is this an
idea already let me give him a boot also
okay
hang on for a moment I was thinking of
maybe even g5 I have not Castle kingside
just yet hmm okay let's throw in a pin
and see how they react
for starters right there
okay I'm gonna play my queen up and one
idea might be Bishop retreat and then
I'm threatening to hunt down the dark
square Bishop now that they've played
their night there hmm should I go should
I go uh Queen side no let's not get too
crazy but let's take this opportunity to
play Knight here this was a bad idea you
know what maybe I'm gonna sack my bishop
no they're going for that and that's
something I didn't think about all right
let's go so looking exciting are you
gonna go pawn hunting really I'm gonna
look to fire up something against the
White King if that you do that don't you
dare grab that beep on okay I could play
this right now I don't see a reason not
to clean here I don't know if I'm Sofia
of that let's give that a shot I guess I
could have gotten there beep Ong Bak
Queen takes B rook out to be eight and
grab here rook F so that I maintain
control of the apone
so Queen here I'm not I'm not getting
the light square bishop and they have
pressure here all right
Queens are gone they have some serious
pressure against this guy
why aren't they recapturing is there
some in-betweener show me the
in-betweener that may be a connection
issue okay I think I'm going to give
this I'm going to throw a question to
the bishop yeah let's do this I want to
be able to play Knight here to reinforce
that pawn so let's get him back into the
ball game where right away if he's
kicked okay well I don't want to give up
my light square bishop so let's go here
don't want to end up in a fork okay so
position is closed and well how are you
gonna go about development hmm well I'm
gonna do this
it's a bit slow they're gonna come in
this direction but one thing I do like
is that let's get this move in for
starters one thing I do like is that the
Queen's are at least off the board this
is like a Kings Indian attack structure
but without the Queen's on the board
what's going for this damage my
structure I'd like to get a knight in to
e5 if you take okay so dar they have
some serious dark square weaknesses they
can't target this guy so easily Bishop
f6 seems to be crying out especially now
since it that only hits the rook but it
stops a knight move here let's take and
then maybe play Knight here next
although this is certainly a move to
consider this is 5l buddy what are you
doing
okay now Knight here get a move on get a
move on fast Knight b3 and you're going
straight in for that okay I guess
they're going to give me both bishops
not a bad idea at all uh-huh so let me
go here I'm anticipating with this some
pressure against d6
I gotta find good squares from my
bishops and I also want to stay out of a
pin bishop c8 I end up in a pin crawling
up into a ball I realize hopefully I
could hold this I want to stop the rook
trades okay how to untangle how to be a
nun tangler okay well let's start with
something all right got to go faster I
think I need
do this I'll see their nights are
monsters man I got a serious case of
monster nights here
I guess what they'll hear oh my goodness
could you move all righty
give this night a kick for a second I
thought they moved I didn't know if just
yet this rook could do something else
maybe um let's just go here keep
pressure on their night I'm really
hesitant to uh let's go here to move my
F pawn because it exposes my king some
I'm pointing at f2 maybe that's
something to target my LightSquared
bishop is not playing let's no let's do
this rook to e1 is probably really
strong hmm or that move yep my pieces
are falling like dominoes now I'd
drop my Jeep on oh boy I thought I had a
moment to save my Jeep on I do okay I
might be untangling with this move Wow
is there Knight trapped I think their
night is trapped still difficult yeah
they're in a pin now they missed that
could even enter with my rook can I make
it happen on the clock that was the big
question Wow Wow
they're getting mated they're getting
mated double checkmate oh man lucky can
you say lucky yep
there's luck in chess it's official it
should not have played out like that for
sure mmm those Knights were monsters
bishop pair versus the night pair in
that particular case yikes
yeah I could do it over how would I do
things a little bit different one thing
that has my attention it must be said is
when it's here in this position I think
I go all the way back hmm
I need to I need to I should have better
anticipated this advance and my knight
being kicked and I didn't and I know I
was drawing some reference to this you
know being like a kings or I don't know
if in the game I was saying king is in
Kings Indian attack anyhow what I meant
was this is like a Kings Indian defense
for black he was looking to play on the
Kings side after this pushes in like
this with this structure why plays on
the Queen side but yeah I I think
this is still something I have to be
very conscious of even though the
Queen's aren't on the board this is
still a good the correct way to approach
it for white to play on the Queen side
and I should have kept this Square open
for my knight is what I'm cutting yet in
so many words here Bishop how did it
play out we have this move and I played
a night here and what I really want to
do is get my night on d7 really soon but
I can't yeah I went with this but
they're just maintaining their pawn this
would be a serious problem because they
never break on the Queen side now and I
have all day to get in my desired f5
break so they did well to reinforce that
point let me put on the computer I think
it was pretty I don't know they're gonna
be saying that it's better for white for
probably the whole game is my guess and
this is this is a good idea this getting
in the pawn break is much more important
I'm playing with two bishops but yeah
I'm really in a way not playing with two
bishops you know that they're they're
not so so great I mean if I'm really
calling this piece right here a bishop
mmm that's a problem he's I don't even
know what you call this guy on e8 well
yeah and I did the problem here is maybe
I should have gone to c8 maybe maybe I
was fearful too much of this but my rook
is protected it's having it as even but
this is this is tough oh no this is
tough because they getting this break
and then my four pawns versus three well
I have an unhealthy four versus three
majority on the Kings side and with this
epon for deep on exchange then I always
have to be a bit concerned clearly about
them these
Ahn's here becoming past d6 like right
around what point as soon as the e5
break came in yeah I see I'm busted here
well okay with my last move I'm busted
because of well
yikes Knight b6 mmm not cool
b5 yeah I'm busted here so I guess it
still is holdable this point let me let
me take it from the top here I don't
think there's too much to really be
pointing out in the opening here
I guess Knight h5 wasn't that as a
problem because of h6
idea and h6 was to play back and I guess
they're quick to open in the center
maybe a bit much to be looking for this
night jump into f4 better to first get a
little bit more development in but why
did I go with this I was let me let me
share why went with Knight h5 here I
don't think I got to share that during
the game but Knight h5 I wanted to get
in so that there isn't some tactical
issue against my night on h5 there's no
you know Queen coming out to take my
night on h5 if the bishop is on g4 and I
thought after castles they could give it
kick and then I don't know just making a
passing move if I try this now
there's some tactic on this square
within Queen takes Knight so my idea was
with Knight to h5 then on h3 I could
take and then maybe jump into f4
no no that's probably still just not the
right idea though
and so yeah to to give up the light
square bishop for the night just to try
and get the night into F for which
there's no guarantee of but there's no
guarantee of any hope on the hh6 move
they could always take with the Queen
and they're watching over this yeah I
shouldn't have gone with the knight to
h5 it's it's too soon to try for this
maneuver
I should have opted for more development
here so Queen b3 they could I guess get
away with taking on v2 but didn't let's
have a look at this here here and this
is no good because of Bishop here or
even stronger so I'm not getting the
pawn back how could white maybe seen
this a little bit better hmm I could see
many players being fearful of this and
just seeing it as well I lose upon or I
went upon but my opponent's gonna win a
right back but is there a way maybe a
question to be asking around this moment
for white is is there a way I can make
good use of the squares that are
weakened in the black position as a
result of that pawn loss the b7 pawn was
he doing he's controlling these squares
Queen a6 there's still pressure
maintained on this square it's what we
might identify is unprotected
now one attacker one defender and there
is a light square bishop around that kid
cause me a problem I think this is
winning material too you know that's a
move as well but this eyeing up the
unprotected rook okay
anyhow they didn't go for that instead
pushed in the center and the evaluation
changes their Queens are off I didn't
really have another move to consider oh
I could still take the bishop here hmm
my queen is protected
okay I should have done that with this
instead got my knight back they want to
take already treated they're suggesting
stay developed but I would have gone all
the way back push here they're still
really quick they're going to get in
that break on the Queen side and another
thing I don't want my knight on this I
don't know if I really like my knight on
the edge here maybe maybe this is a
better idea
this night for Bishop exchange is much
better if the Queen's are still on the
board because maybe that pond kid could
turn out to be I don't know you could
kind of combine that pond with another
pond at some point and it looked to
attack the king by having a pond with a
little bit of depth but he's one who is
really well controlled I mean that's as
far as he's going I'm not getting in f3
ever I'm just what I'm what I'm doing
here is I'm just trying to understand
some of the differences with in exchange
on c4 or you know a case of double deaf
pawns in a position where there aren't
Queens and are Queens I think I would
much rather play this position with
Queens still on the board if I have my
pawn doubled like this then without
Queens on the board so maybe I should
stay away from Knight f4 although the
computer doesn't seem to agree okay well
a lot of stuff missed already up into
this point with 85 they were with 83
holding it as even how could I have done
better right around here
rook invasion hmm yeah this is a moment
I could make use of the open file
there's no reason you shouldn't be going
there you improved the position of your
piece and you throw a strong punch mm mm
okay
I went with v6 still trying my best to
prevent this break but in the end what
happened the break still came about this
was a nice idea and you know I am on the
defensive now I have to prepare to
defend one of my pawns who is soon to be
a target I take like this guess who's
the target it's tough it is tough so
they're suggesting just doubling oh okay
and then we could meet this move with
rook here I guess that this is an idea
and then I could come over I don't know
if I expressed it during the game but
what I really wanted to have happen is
one pair of Brooks come off just so I
could have my King come over to the
defense of the pawn without as much fear
of some tactics mm-hmm
you know it's still both knights and
both rooks on the board it's much more
tactical and pewter likes Bishop to c8
c8 you know it's only a half pawn
advantage right around this point but
it's tricky to play on the black side
and that's a blunder right into the line
of fire
a missed opportunity for my opponent and
I could basically resign these guys
there
White is playing with three rooks soon
two ponds on the sixth ranked beasts
they even outweigh a rook so yeah what
am I to do here instead of Bishop to e7
they want to just give up the bishop and
then come over I don't know about King
g7 I probably go like this and I hear
maybe I could even take actually I know
they're getting a pond but this is maybe
holdable huh yeah it says a pond
advantage but I should be able to hold
this still tricky hmm okay well we
didn't have Bishop for Knight exchange
and I am just worse off from here on out
no Bishop here rook to e1 it did pop up
for a second I thought that that would
be strong
threatening Knight discoveries because
this is the only square my king could be
on to maintain control of my bishop so
yeah rook to e1 would have been strong
night there +4 they could take here and
now it's a connected passed pawn and
he's just a dead piece dead I have no
possibility of activating him either if
I touch this pawn this night will kill
me okay
yeah dodged a great bullet many times
over this one they have their
opportunity to take on h6 g5 here and I
think well they certainly weren't in as
much time pressure as myself but uh yeah
they have their opportunities and now
I'm just winning the first the first
time I get to develop my bishop the
first time that my LightScribe bishops
presence has actually felt in it in the
game only at this point do I actually
yeah that's I'm winning from here but
lucky to have even gotten in this
position clearly
there's no defense here I guess for
white a night here I immediately attack
him what ran through my mind is
capturing but I saw that they could take
and then the night has a way to escape
although I guess things are still pretty
good but most convincing is to
immediately just challenge this night
and they could push I could take here
and yeah then on this capture I could be
quickly recapturing it takes I take the
night push here and then slowly come
over here with my king my bishop is
gluing everything together and yeah
should be straightforward I'm off a
piece there but yeah lucky to you have
even in that position for sure and
finished off with that double checkmate
yikes okay well a lot of things missed
in that one but as usual feel free to
leave any feedback in the comment
section below to this video and as usual
I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you